vous vous souvenez d'Owen Shaw celui que nous avons déchiré la
moitié de Londres en Chine a bien
fait c'est le grand méchant frère
assassin des forces spéciales britanniques actuellement un
atout unique qu'aucun gouvernement
n'admettrait jamais utiliser comment puis-je le trouver
la réponse officielle est que vous ne le faites pas
il a tué Han, j'ai presque coupé ma famille, il a
aussi essayé de me mettre dans un sac mortuaire aussi,
c'est pourquoi quand je sortirai, je vais le
blesser si fort qu'il souhaitera que
sa maman ait gardé les jambes fermées mais
jusque-là  ma réponse officielle est de
se retirer ouais tu sais que je ne peux pas je ne sais pas
tu es stupide c'est pourquoi maintenant je te donne la
réponse de frère à frère tu fais
tout ce que tu as à faire quand tu
trouves cette [ __ ] juste  fais moi une faveur
qu'est ce que c'est ne manquez pas